i needed to like take a step back and
really evaluate my relationship with
social media and i think i found a nice
balance hi my name is sadie sink and
this is my glamour unfiltered
confidence is something that kind of
goes up and down and sometimes you can
feel really confident and other times
you're a little bit more insecure but i
think definitely playing the role of max
who is for the most part a very
outspoken and bold and confident person
that's like helped me a little on my
journey to
become like my most confident self but
it's it's always fluctuating it's never
it's never the same throughout like
middle school in high school i don't
think there was ever a moment where i
wasn't like doubting myself or like
feeling insecure and just like trying to
find myself i guess i'm not sure when it
was but like i hit a certain point where
maybe i was wearing like finally wearing
an outfit that i felt like really
comfortable in or felt like i kind of
like put a pinpoint on my personal style
where i was like okay i think i think
this is who i am
um but definitely you have to like get
past those teenage years
growing up in this industry especially
and i started when i was really young
like 10 you're around a lot of other
actors your age and i think you kind of
always compare yourself to them or you
start doubting your abilities that was
probably where my biggest insecurities
lie just in terms of like
i don't know coming into my own as an
actress when i am on set that's probably
when i am the most empowered
um
just kind of
doing what i love and what i've always
loved since you know i was
six seven eight whatever that's probably
when i feel
the best and
i'm able to just kind of like focus on
the work that i'm doing or whatever
character i'm playing and it's kind of
like my comfort zone it was kind of
amazing like the bond between all of us
was pretty instantaneous and i think
over time
it just gets stronger and stronger it's
really nice having
just a solid support group that's going
through the same thing that you're going
through
um and makes just being on set that much
more fun like my relationship with each
cast member is so different and so
unique and special they're all just the
best i'd say it's really important to
trust each other and be honest with each
other
um
it's also nice having
those people that you've known like for
most of your life like for me i think my
best friend is the world is like my
brother like my brother's my best friend
in the world you know we trust each
other and we're open and honest with
each other
and
he's obviously i've known him forever so
it's it's a very special bond i mean
she's someone that i've always wanted to
work with but never thought that i would
on anything because i never thought like
our paths would cross in any way
um
but she's such an incredible human being
and so smart
so grounded just everything you'd want
her to be and just like as a friend as a
director as a mentor like it's really
incredible to have her and that
experience was um
it was it was really really special and
yeah it was it was kind of a cool
opportunity to
step out of like
i don't know being like a kid
kid on screen i guess
um
but yeah and of course it's like such a
such an iconic song and the way she kind
of like
um
brought that to life on screen was
really special so it's like an honor to
be a part of it i mean it's kind of wild
but
especially joining the show when it was
already such a success
so we kind of like had a had a little
glimpse of what i was getting into
it definitely wasn't easy
at first because i was i was never used
to like some of these events that you'd
go to or like the photo shoots are like
this you know like i never i never had
that so
getting used to that was kind of that
was a process um
but i'd say like the best thing that
works for me is just spending time with
my family and and focusing on like the
work part of it um
but having like a good solid support
system
is
so important and
just kind of feeling like you're
surrounded by people who have your best
interests at heart and not getting too
caught up or overwhelmed with everything
i
learned pretty early on that like having
social media on my phone wasn't the best
thing for me so i don't really have
the app for like instagram or twitter i
think i have a twitter i'm not sure i
think i do but um like i don't keep it
on my phone or anything sometimes i'll
have it like if i'm feeling like i want
it but not all the time
um just because i think
it's
what's best for me and especially when
the show first came out it was like a
lot of attention all at once
so it kind of um
i don't know it didn't scare me off but
i was just like whoa i wasn't expecting
it so i needed to like take a step back
and really evaluate my relationship with
social media
and i think i've found a nice balance
like if i have a photo that i like maybe
i'll post it maybe i won't maybe i'll
look at the app every once in a while
most likely i won't but
i don't know it's some people love it
some people don't like it i'm kind of
indifferent
i think it's important to like feel
everything you're feeling also so if
like you are feeling hurt by something
it's okay like let yourself feel hurt
and ride that out
um and just kind of like learn from it
too so for me if i ever see something
rude or whatever if i have like a i
don't know like a bad day at work or i'm
thinking about like something i did on
set like oh man i should have said that
line differently you can sit with it for
a little bit but then just like go to
bed wake up the next morning start fresh
that's kind of what i do
when dealing with like body image issues
or just kind of like being a young woman
in today's society
there's a lot of issues that come with
that but
i think
it's important yeah to like have someone
you can talk to about it if you really
need that um for me
i think it's just
i focus on like what's real and like
real life and my friends and the people
in my circle
um rather than kind of paying attention
to
everything else that's going on
in the world in terms of like pictures
that other people are posting or what
are they wearing or what should i be
wearing what makeup should i be wearing
um
but it's just kind of important to focus
on
what's real for most of the time i'd say
i don't know i feel most like myself
when i'm just
at home doing absolutely nothing like
when it's just me
rupaul's drag race and that's about it
um yeah i'd say i'd say like being just
a with my family i say that a lot but it
really is the truth like it's just
people that know you and aren't asking
anything from you and you're just able
to be fully yourself around and not
worry about
i don't know what what you're saying or
what you look like you can just kind of
let loose